[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans cette édition
spéciale consacrée au corona virus dans
les yvelines
au sommaire ce vendredi 13 mars celle
annonces phares du président de la
république pour lutter contre la
pandémie la propagation virus sur le
territoire
la fermeture des établissements
scolaires de la crèche à l'université
décidé à partir de lundi nous ferons le
point sur l'organisation dans les
éléments avec la restriction de
rassemblements de population limitée à
100 personnes annoncées par le premier
ministre vendredi de nombreux événements
danse annulé coup dresseront un état des
lieux de toutes les annulations depuis
déjà plus d'une semaine les et vince ont
touché par le coc u19 nous reviendrons
sur les mesures qui avaient déjà été
prises dans les villes concernées dès
lundi et jusqu'à nouvel ordre les
crèches les écoles les collèges les
lycées et des universités seront fermés
c'était jeudi soir dans cette allocation
présidentiel consacré à la crise
pandémique coronavirus qu emmanuel
macron a qualifié de plus graves crises
sanitaires qu'a connue la france depuis
un siècle
plusieurs grandes annonces dont celle de
la fermeture de tous les établissements
scolaires dès lundi plus de trois cent
cinq mille élèves concernés des écoles
lycées
une mesure qui pousse institutions et
parents d'élèves à s'organiser
mélanie poké manon varaldo se sont
rendus devant l'école l'école
élémentaire françois mansart à lui en
cours vendredi après midi
pour l'instant je garde des enfants donc
que après c'est parce que moi je le
disais délai 6 1 et débattu en fait donc
un peu les pieds de grue pour garder les
pieds au fait
donc pour moi il n'ya pas y aura pas de
problème en fait moi chaîne médico
psychologique ce travail dans un foyer
pour adultes polyhandicapés donc bah on
n'a pas le choix on doit travailler
j'ai la chance que mon mari puis
s'occuper du petit donc c'est lui qui
restera à la maison c'est problématique
pour plein de parents et moi je suis pas
concerné ce que je suis assistante
maternelle donc mes enfants je vais les
garder avec ce que j ai déjà mai
le problème c'est de savoir combien de
temps ça va durer pas pour problèmes de
garde pour moi mais pour l'école
j'espère que ça va de même moins
longtemps possible mais bon pour
l'instant on n'a pas le choix on va
faire avec et on aura j'espère que ça va
s'arranger pour tout le monde c'est
important la santé avant tout et donc
c'est vrai que c'est un petit sacrifice
un gros sacrifice pour les enfants
mais c'est vrai que le plus important ça
va être justement de tout se protéger et
faire face à cette épidémie voir
pandémie comme ils le disent et pour
gérer la situation éducative dans le
département une cellule de crise est
installée au sein des locaux de la
direction académique des yvelines
elle est ouverte depuis deux semaines et
fonctionne de 8h à 17h30 deux équipes se
relaient pour assurer une permanence
téléphonique tout au long de la journée
et répondre aux questions des directeurs
des établissements scolaires et des
inspecteurs de l'éducation nationale
la rectrice de l'académie de versailles
a rendu visite à la cellule vendredi
l'occasion pour charline à venelles de
préciser le dispositif pour assurer la
continuité pédagogique pendant la
période de fermeture
propos recueillis par grégory canal et
qu'elle passe par plusieurs éléments
elle passe par des des modalités de
d'enseignement à distance qui sont
prévues par le cned mais on a aussi
d'autres ressources qui passe par les
ent ou par des blogs d'enseignants et
puis cela passe par la possibilité
d'ouvrir des classes virtuelles une
classe virtuelle c'est un écran la
classe le professeur un tableau sur
lequel on peut écrire la possibilité de
lever la main de répondre et d'interagir
avec les élèves et la rectrice a précisé
que les établissements scolaires est
resté ouvert pour les enseignants des
réunions pédagogiques continuerons de
soutenir les professeurs pourront y
assurer les cours avec leur classe
virtuelle
les professeurs qui sont d'ailleurs dans
l'un tente d' informations
supplémentaires concernant
l'enseignement à distance
on écoute bertrand mesure secrétaire
départemental du syndicat sms émis pp
des yvelines le système éducatif
n'étaient pas du tout préparés à ce type
de d'événements les choses se sont
construits en cours de route
avec parfois des incohérences et du
cafouillage même si les choses étaient
en train de se stabiliser
maintenant ce qui concerne la phase qui
va arriver c'est à dire les trois
semaines et puis
par contre là on peut dire que
clairement le ministre de l'éducation
nationale est à côté de la réalité quand
ils pensent que le système éducatif est
prêt à faire l'enseignement à distance
qui a présenté aux parents comme étant
une pure formalité
de son côté l'université versailles
saint quentin en yvelines a enchaîné les
réunions de crise tout ce vendredi
d'après nos informations plusieurs
questions se posent les annulations des
événements et conférences l'ouverture ou
non des bibliothèques universitaires le
maintien des élections à la présidence
de l'université prévues le 31 mars
concernant les bibliothèques
universitaires les pénalités de retard
sont annulés pour l'emprunt des livres
et la bibliothèque numérique est un et
bien sûr accessible une réflexion
intense concernant la continuité
pédagogique qui est la priorité des
équipes ainsi que la possibilité de
faire les examens à distance lu vs cul
qui avait pris les devants avec un plan
de maintien d'activités travail lié
depuis deux semaines notamment
concernant les laboratoires et le
fonctionnement administratif
on rappelle qu'au moment où nous
enregistrons cette émission aucun cas de
coronavirus n'a été détecté au sein de
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines qui met tout en oeuvre pour
informer au mieux ces étudiants et son
personnel
tous sont invités à suivre les dernières
informations sur le site internet et les
réseaux sociaux de lever excuse des
étudiants qui se montre compréhensif
mais tout de même inquiet pour la suite
de leurs examens à venir
mélanie poké émanant varaldo les ont
interrogés devant la bibliothèque
universitaire depuis en cours
premièrement j'ai été déçu de la
réaction mais ensuite j'ai direct
compris parce que je pense qu'il faut
prendre des mesures face à ça et depuis
on a on a récemment appris que les
jeunes pouvaient aussi contracté le
virus autres alors qu'au début on
pensait que c'était unique pour les
personnes âgées du coup c'est des bonnes
mesures
les étudiants les écoliers se déplacent
partout en france
ils prennent les transports si on veut
réduire l'impact d'une épidémie ouais
c'est ce qu'il faut faire c'est sur moi
mais je me peux surtout beaucoup de
questions parce qu'on est en l3 donc on
joue aussi notre diplôme de licence et
on n'a pas forcément pour l'instant
encore toutes les informations de
comment ça va se mettre en place pour
les contrôler les évaluations les euros
qu'on fait en cours
d'un côté c'est bien parce que voilà ça
protège la population tout ça mais pour
les étudiants je trouve ça un peu
dangereux quand même on a déjà eu les
grèves qui ont touché énormément de
soucis et en plus des mesures qui nous
interdit d'aller à la fac ça va être
encore pire et si les établissements
scolaires s'organisent les institutions
locales
aussi ce vendredi matin les élus et le
comité de direction de saint quentin en
yvelines se sont réunis un point sur les
décisions prises tous les événements
sont annulés jusqu'à nouvel ordre
sont aussi fermés au public dès vendredi
soir les médiathèques le musée de la
ville la commanderie le théâtre national
idem pour la piscine des
clayes-sous-bois la cité des métiers et
encore la maison de justice et du droit
le ski cube quant à lui est fermée au
public mais les entreprises accueillies
peuvent toujours y travailler et les
événements sont amenés à être remplacés
par des visioconférences saint quentin
en yvelines annonce aussi accompagner
entreprises et commerçants dans leur
démarche pour les prochains jours
lundi un plan de continuité d'activité
sera diffusé il contiendra les bleus
surprise pour protéger les agents de
l'agglomération et permettra la
poursuite des services des numéros verts
sont disponibles pour les consultations
par téléphone les yvelines qui ne sont
pas épargnés par le coronavirus alors
nous enregistrons cette émission le
vendredi 13 mars laissant cas
diagnostiqués ont été dépassés dont
quatre décès selon la préfecture
cette quatrième victime était âgée de 85
ans et était hospitalisée à versailles
les trois autres étaient des résidents
de maisons de retraite de saint germain
en laye égyptienne pour absorber le
nombre important de patients qui
s'apprête à venir dans les jours à
suivre
le centre hospitalier de versailles
lance un appel aux professionnels de
santé pour venir en renfort pour cela il
faut s'inscrire sur leur service des
remplacements hung avec le code
établissements ch les 78 puis envoyé un
mail à l'adresse renfort rh
@ c'est ch ch tirait versailles point fr
la propagation du corona virus et la
pandémie de kovy 19 suscite des craintes
et des interrogations
le taux de mortalité dû coronavirus
élèves progressive
avec l'âge les personnes de plus de 80
ans sont plus fragiles mais les plus
jeunes peuvent l'attraper
manon par aldo comment savoir si je suis
attendu coronavirus alors tout d'abord
vous aurez de la fièvre une toux sèche
le nez qui coule c'est assez banal
un peu comme la grippe seul un test peut
confirmer si vous avez le coronavirus ou
pas les personnes déjà malades sont plus
susceptibles de l'attraper en
particulier si elles souffrent d'une
maladie cardiovasculaire ou les
personnes souffrant d'hypertension
mais aussi elles les personnes atteintes
d'un cancer les diabétiques les
personnes atteintes de maladies
respiratoires chroniques comme les
asthmatiques sont des personnes
vulnérables face aux coronavirus les
fumeurs sont également des personnes à
risque
et comment le corona virus se transmet
tel quels sont les bons gestes à adopter
il existe deux modes de transmission du
coronavirus les postillons qu'une
personne infectée pourrait projeter avec
une quinte de toux ou d'éternuement ce
sont ces gouttelettes profiter quand on
éternue canton tout ce qu'ils vont
transmettre le qu'ovide 19
il faut donc éviter les contacts trop
rapprochée si vous avez envie d'éternuer
marylène de tous et fait ça à distance
de vos proches et dans votre coude
utiliser des mouchoirs jetables bien sûr
à usage unique il est également possible
de contracter le coronavirus en se
touchant les yeux le nez ou la bouche
après que vaudois était en contact avec
une surface contaminée
il s'agit par exemple d'une poignée de
porte un téléphone portable un clavier
d'ordinateur
ce sont ce que l'on appelle des surfaces
inerte sur lesquels le virus peut
survivre plusieurs heures
ainsi l avez-vous a régulièrement les
mains à l'eau chaude avec du savon en
insistant sur les espaces entre vos
doigts en ayant une attention
particulière pour vos pouces et pour le
dessus de vos mains signé jamais vous
n'avez pas d'eau à proximité
elle n'hésitait pas à utiliser du gel
hydroalcoolique
enfin surveiller votre température en la
prenant deux fois par jour
au besoin un numéro vert est mis à votre
disposition
le 0 800 130 000
alors on leur tiendra bien se laver les
mains merci manon pour tous ces éléments
alors autre annonce attendue du
président de la république la décision
concernant les élections municipales
elles sont maintenues pour assurer la
continuité des institutions toutes les
mairies ont reçu une circulaire avec des
recommandations sanitaires pour les
bureaux de vote avec par exemple une
limitation des situations de proximité à
l'aide d'un marquage au sol
un point pour se laver les mains doit
être mis à disposition des électeurs et
des membres du bureau de vote
un nettoyage doit être effectué
plusieurs fois dans la journée les
électeurs sont invités à venir avec leur
propre stylo bleu ou noir
n'hésitez pas à vous rendre sur les
sites internet de vos communes pour en
savoir plus et tout au long de la
semaine déjà des mesures avaient été
prises dans les yvelines sur des cas
spécifiques dans les dès lundi le préfet
des yvelines le maire de poissy l'
agence régionale de santé et l'éducation
nationale prenait la décision de fermer
l'école élémentaire des sablons à poissy
une enseignante de l'établissement qui
compte 15 classés 3 198 élèves a été
testée positive au grenat virus elle est
naturellement confiné à son domicile et
la rs enquête pour connaître les
personnes qui auraient pu être en
contact avec l'institutrice une
fermeture d'école mais la continuité
pédagogique assuré on écoute le
directeur académique des yvelines
comme cette enseignante de ce1 a fait
des cures de chorales à d'autres enfants
de l'école en fait la décision a été
prise de ne pas faire les simplement la
classe mais toute l'école et donc on est
en train d'organiser de la continuité
pédagogique
voyez les enseignants parents vont
devoir préparer des exercices
d'entraînement pour les élèves et les
seins pour un ou deux jours et les
femmes ils vont être informés que ces
exercices d'entraînement
elles sont à consulter sur un blog et
que en cliquant sur ce blog la classe de
ce1
par exemple si mon enfant et en c1 eh
bien j'ai accès aux exercices que la
maîtresse ou le mettre à préparer pour
les deux jours à venir
on est en train de tout organiser pour
que les enfants perdent pas leur temps
et puis ce
chez de travailler quoi on a inventé ce
matin des modalités même si l'on s'y
prépare depuis quinze jours mais en tout
cas une chose très pratico pratique coin
averse à une professeure de l'école
lully vauban et était a été testée
positive au corona virus lundi l'élu
classe à qui elle faisait cours ont été
fermés reportage de mathilde de 2 min et
patrick jacques de dixmude la décision
ne faisait plus de doute après le test
positif au coronavirus d'une enseignante
de musique lundi 9 mars les autorités
ont acté la fermeture de huit classes à
l'école élémentaire lully vauban à
versailles
la rectrice de l'académie a rencontré
les professeurs pour échanger avec eux
des mesures à prendre et de la
continuité pédagogique a assuré les
éléments de la continuité pédagogique
c'est permettre à chaque enfant pendant
les 15 jours qui sont devant nous
d'avoir accès
à des contenus et à son programme donc
on fait les enseignants ici eh bien ils
ont mis en place un blog
en effet j'ai vivement conseillé aux
enseignants d'essayer la classe
virtuelle la classe virtuelle c'est un
ordinateur devant soi on a face à soi
l'ensemble des élèves lesquels peuvent
lever la main intervenir
on a un tableau sur lequel on peut
écrire et donc être dans une
configuration de classe tout à fait tout
à fait normal tweed au confinement de
l'enseignante qui a contracté le
qu'ovide 19 le corps enseignant a de
suite réagi en créant un blog pour
fournir du travail aux élèves isolé ça
du coup les enseignants vont pouvoir
déposer du contenu pédagogique savoir
des extraits de manuel qu'ils ont pu
scanner ou pris en photo des exercices à
faire en plus des vidéos à regarder sur
différents sites notamment en anglais
puis d'autres choses en fonction de leur
projet de classe les parents d'élèves
confiné ont pu trouver sur le site de
l'école le lien du blog celui classe sur
18 ont été fermées à l'école lully
vauban le directeur a reçu dans la
matinée les parents inquiets certains
sont inquiets certains sur la
compréhension pourquoi telle classe et
va c'est pourquoi pas telle autre
on leur expliquait que c'était les
classes qui avaient été en contact avec
l'enseignante en question l'état de
santé de l'enseignante de musique
n'inspire pas d'inquiétude selon la
préfecture les classes concernées
resteront fermées pendant 14 jours les
élèves pourront revenir à compter du 20
mars et la maison de retraite du coeur
volant à louveciennes a fermé ses portes
aux visiteurs dès dimanche 8 mars suite
à quatre cas avérés de qourna virus chez
des résidents deux d'entre eux sont
décédés depuis mercredi le gouvernement
demandé à toutes les maisons de retraite
suspende l'intégralité des visites de
personnes extérieures
les personnes âgées étant
particulièrement vulnérables aux
coronavirus le président de la
république a d'ailleurs incité les
personnes de plus de 70 ans à limiter au
maximum leurs sorties de domicile les
professionnels de santé sont
particulièrement sollicités et parmi eux
les pharmaciens le ministre de la santé
a signé un arrêté leur autorisant à
produire leurs propres solutions hydro
alcooliques pour parer à la rupture de
stock
renault nadjani président de l'uar ps
pharmaciens ile de france étaient en
plateau du set
journal lundi le rôle de pharmaciens ces
deux d'essayer de calmer le jeu de
remettre les choses à leur juste niveau
bien sûr il faut encore une fois être
prudent et le pharmacien fait cette ce
conseil est cet accompagnement tout au
long de l'année
tout le temps là on met en lumière
effectivement parce qu'il parce que
c'est sous tension mais c'est notre
métier que d'accompagner dans ce cadre
là mais aussi dans la traumatologie et
un certain nombre de pathologies que le
pharmacien désengorge notamment les
services de soins et je crois qu'il est
important de d'identifier de souligner
cette action qui devrait être comment
dire encore plus mis en avant une crise
épidémique qui a un impact économique
vous pouvez retrouver le cette ut co2
nicolas tendre et qui abordera cette
thématique
la situation actuelle en train de bien
sûr des annulations dans le monde
sportif et culturel avec cette dernière
annonce du premier ministre edouard
philippe de limiter les rassemblements à
100 personnes ont fait le point avec
mélanie poquet journalistes de la
rédaction
alors à l'instant nous enregistrons
cette émission moyenne toutes les
situations ne sont pas encore connues il
ya encore des réunions qui sont en cours
mais ce que nous savons déjà c'est du
côté du monde du football il n'ya pas
que les professionnels qui sont touchés
tous les matches sont annulés
près de 350 rencontres sont concernés
pour les ive et on écoute jean pierre
meurillon il est le président du
district du football des idées qu'on
appelle l'attention des clubs sur le
fait que ça concerne non seulement les
zélés les les compétitions les
rassemblements etc mais aussi les
entraînements les activités des écoles
de football etc et que donc il faut se
conformer à ça puisque c'est ce sont les
instructions qui nous chantonnay alors
côté culture aussi on a des amis nation
a noté et oui ils auront tenté
d'organiser leurs événements jusqu'au
bout mais après les annonces du premier
ministre ce midi interdisant les
manifestations regroupant plus de 100
personnes les organes les organisateurs
de la foire de châteaux ont dû se
résoudre à annuler leurs événements
la centième fois on aura été présentes
que ce vendredi 13 mars et du côté de
saint quentin en yvelines
la déception elle est aussi du côté du
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines les
rencontres in cité aurait dû se tenir du
14 au 21 mars alors que les compagnies
étaient déjà arrivés les scènes
installées les représentations sont
annulés certaines sont reportés sur la
saison 2021 2022 mais les équipes
organisatrices maintiennent les tables
rondes en un format plutôt original
écouter lionel masse et à le directeur
de la scène nationale
elles seront en revanche organisé en
principe j'attends les réponses encore
de tous les intervenants à huis clos
face on imite une émission radio au
studio télé et diffusée soit soit sur
nos sur nos réseaux sociaux soit sur
notre site web
parce que je pense que la parole des
lithiases invités il y avait des invités
après intéressant prestigieux donc on
avait envie de garder ces paroles là il
ya quand même les événements qui se
maintiennent ou via l'heure actuelle est
maintenue le festival électro de
versailles grand parc et les ciné
concerts et les soirées dans les plus
petites salles sont maintenus puisqu'ils
accueilleront moins 200 personnes sont
pas content reporté le concert prequel
au montansier la grande soirée à lons
n'hésitez pas à vous rendre
régulièrement sur la page facebook du
festival pour vous tenir au courant
merci née l'année pour ce point global
n'hésitez pas à donc à consulter les
sites internet des liens des lieux
d'accueil de votre sortie nous venons
d'apprendre par exemple la fermeture du
château de versailles
ce soir et jusqu'à nouvel ordre autre
événement sportif d'envergure perturber
le paillis dès son départ de plaisir
dimanche 8 mars
des précautions sanitaires ont été
prises conférence de presse supprimer
poignée de main interdite et speaker
plus qu'on sait que d'habitude
manou varaldo la course paris-nice est
parti pour sa 11e édition depuis les
yvelines mais cette année les
spectateurs ne pouvait pas s'approcher
des bus et des coureurs pour cause de
consignes liés à l'épidémie de
coronavirus c'était des zorra moi j'ai
posé la question c'est l'événement
allait être maintenue parce que
vu que ya le corps à un virus et c'est
vraiment une tragédie pour les
événements sportifs en général de ce que
je vois je pense qu'il n'y a pas
beaucoup de monde parce que l'événement
fait que les gens ont peu peur le public
était moins nombreux cette année mais
les vedettes de la célèbre course n'ont
pas manqué le rendez vous
[Musique]
les coureurs sont montés sur le podium
mais le speaker avaient pour consigne de
ne pas les interroger
thomas voeckler ancien cycliste a remis
aux jeunes pédaleurs yvelinois un casque
julian alain philippe a reçu le prix du
fair play il avait donné lors du tour de
france son maillot jaune un enfant sur
le bord de la route qui avait froid
les cyclistes eux ont dû braver la pluie
à 11h top départ pour les coureurs du
paris nice hier dimanche ils se sont
élancés depuis plaisir ce jeune de 11
ans a lui aussi tout données cvs d'aller
vous pouvez ainsi si nous avions les
jambes
malgré la pluie le public s'est essayé
aux animations autour du vélo proposé
dans le village du paris nice on a le
freestyle airbag qu'un gros coussins
géants où c'est une vraie table
structure d'initiation et d'entraînement
puisqu'il ya des éducateurs qui sont
présents aussi pas aussi le draisienne
parc donc est vraiment un parcours de
tri sienne pour les pour les enfants
c'est parti j'ai fait la course en vélo
après j'ai fait un simulateur de pente
en vélo les freestyle qui sont juste là
bas abbas et qu'on les voit faire des
détours de salto c'est super autre
animation ce jeune homme de 16 ans
pratique le trial depuis quatre ans dans
un club à epône il enchaîne figure et
obstacles sous les yeux des spectateurs
et pour le franchir avec leurs plus
belles et meilleures techniques pour
pouvoir aller plus en plus haut et ça
demande pas mal d'entraînement et faut
le faire sérieusement l'entraînement
folle et du sérieux il y en avait avec
le coronavirus les précautions étaient
de mise est des gants pour toucher les
guidons des vélos du village
d'animations c'était très sportif on s'y
attendait pas mais effectivement c'était
assez sportif où j'ai dû me battre
contre le vélo bloc essayer de me
rattraper
mais c'était très sympa c'est un très
beau
événement qu'on plaisir mais surtout et
pour
anne pingeot
roland polydor avec le coronavirus cette
équipe ont décliné leur participation à
cette course mais l'organisation a
ouvert les inscriptions à d'autres
groupes
une première étape à plaisir remporté
par maximilian sharman le paris nice qui
se termine finalement samedi et non
dimanche comme prévu la dernière étape
étant annulé l'épreuve s'achève donc au
sommet de la colmiane avant même cette
annonce l'équipe pareils mclaren s'est
retirée vendredi matin on arrive à la
fin de cette édition spéciale n'oubliez
pas dimanche 15 mars toutes les équipes
de tv 78,2 vous font vivre le premier
tour des élections municipales en direct
dès 19h30 le 7-8 journal il sera
consacrée lundi et bien sûr nous
reviendrons sur les mesures et
conséquences concernant le coronavirus
bon week-end sûreté des 78
[Musique]